this is a kind of No Frills um update on
myself
um as you can see I've lost my hair
Sunita Finn's chemotherapy started in
the middle of the pandemic
she had been diagnosed with ovarian
cancer for a second time
throughout her treatment she suffered
delays including major surgery to remove
her ovaries
now she's facing them again as she waits
to find out if she is finally
cancer-free
it's been really difficult to to see the
the deterioration of services and
you know I've spoken to some nurses and
they're like we they don't want to be
striking but they don't feel that they
can provide the level of care and and
they were
I swear to God a guardian angels for me
nurse is striking demanding change
it's delays of care to patients like
Sunita and disputes over pay that has
led to this we have to do this in order
to secure safe patient care within five
to ten years otherwise our service will
decline much further and we have nothing
left
and coming soon a day Health leaders
have been dreading the GMB Union has
announced four new strike dates for
ambulance workers including the 6th of
February when they will stand alongside
nurses on the picket line
it was perhaps inevitable that the
longer the disputes dragged on you'd
have more than one health union calling
for industrial action on the same day
that puts more pressure on the trusts
and on patience with delayed operations
and canceled appointments and patients
not presenting at hospital
the health secretary says his door is
open but he insists he cannot offer
above inflation pay Rises
what matters most not just at NHS staff
but all stuff is that we get inflation
down because inflation it cuts across
the cost of living for NHS staff social
Care staff but people across the economy
the government and striking health
workers are as far apart now as they
were at the start of the dispute and
there's no settlement in sight that
means more pressure for the NHS
and it's patience Ashish Josh is Sky
News in central London